and now on to our top story tonight a
giant and the Democratic Party I just
mentioned is being robbed rocked by a
second allegation of sexual misconduct
the second as many as dit as two days
Congressman John Conyers paid his
accuser $27,000
out of a congressional account in 2015
that drove another accuser to depression
the ethics committee is already
investigating Conyers but is that enough
and should taxpayers be on the hook for
his misdeeds here to react is Kimberly
Whaley she's a professor of law at the
University of Baltimore and congressman
Ryan Costello a Republican from
Pennsylvania it's great to see both of
you happy Thanksgiving and all that jazz
professor let's talk to you this is some
wild stuff and we have had a cavalcade
of accusations some more recent than
others some really old sweet both
Hollywood business media and politics
what is your take on this Conyers issue
now that we know he used his own budget
his office budget to pay some of these
settlements well some one thing that's
been striking to me is the fact that the
our elected officials are seem to be
less accountable than those in the
private sector right so we've seen it
sweep through Hollywood we've seen it
happen in the halls of corporate America
and and the retribution is Swift and the
people are moved out and new people
moved in presumably and the notion is
that that there's money at stake right
and so when it comes to our elected
officials without a will to actually
remove them from office from the voter
standpoint there's really not much that
we can do the Constitution doesn't say
much about its congressman Costello to
you on this this is what Maxine Waters
congresswoman waters said not too long
ago about congressman Conyers it was a
big woman's forum let's watch there is a
member of Congress who has been
supportive of women for many many years
he is quiet he is confident he is
powerful but he has impeccable integrity
on all of our issues
give john conyers a big round of
applause whoa I'm just giving him a big
round of applause impeccable integrity
congressman Costello you heard the
professor that look the Congress seems
to have its own set of rules that's how
its constituted they govern themselves
they pass their own ethics rules
internal rules and regulations but is it
time that things begin to change I mean
a lot of you guys didn't even know this
slush Schuss fund even existed the short
answer is things do need to change I
think that this legislation is a step in
the right direction because if you work
on Capitol Hill
and you've been mistreated the process
that you have to go through in order to
file a complaint and have your grievance
heard is so opaque confusing that it's
just not fair it's not fair and it's not
right and I think the slush fund that
you spoke to is sort of indicative of
the American public's frustration with
at times how Congress is governed they
feel that there's a different set of
rules for members of Congress and the
point here is look as a member of
Congress I have a budget I pay staff
office supplies office space etc etc
that money should not and cannot be
allowed for use to pay off an employee
who may have been mistreated that has to
end I don't think it's my question here
is is that even allowed
I don't believe that it is No okay so
this will be part of an ongoing ethics
investigation into John Conyers I want
you to speak to my my my angle that I
gave at the top of the show we got
people in Congress have been there a
half a century plus now I think old
people senior people like we're all
getting up there okay they have a lot of
wisdom but this was not meant to be a
permanent job security program working
on Capitol Hill but we got people up
here for three decades for decades and
in case of John Conyers five decades
you kind of get removed from the people
after five decades you go from sedan
fundraiser to lobbyists to consultant to
this and that and the people or whether
were the heck of the people and all that
that's going to be up to vote
unless we have term limits I mean look
the reality is that that fund some of
that may have been a sexual
discrimination claims a lot of that was
workplace violation some of it could
have been age discrimination right so I
yeah there's a couple different ways to
look at that but I understand the sense
of the American people is sometimes
members of Congress are there are too
long obviously it's up to the
constituents in their district to vote
them out if they don't want them there
but we're dealing here with the
situation where when improper conduct
does occur are the mechanisms in place
in order to to right the situation to
treat a young woman who may have been
mistreated and I think that there's a
feeling that the mechanisms that are in
place now are insufficient there's not
you seem like a nice guy and I'm sure
you represent your constituents and very
well but as a professor is pointing out
I mean you know you can't get away with
this stuff and in corporate America
anymore at least you shouldn't and the
the fact that women are forced into
mandatory counseling and professor I
want you to get into that this is one is
now on Capitol Hill women who accuse or
men who accuse others of sexual
misconduct other Miska have to go into
force counseling mandatory about 30 days
30 days and then there's 30 days of
media the other way
yeah the counseling so people are doing
the conduct professor I want you to
weigh no it's true well I mean crazy
under the Constitution the way you get
rid of members of Congress no ma'am well
or under Article one you can the other
members of the Senate can and it's in
the senate context can actually expel
that well that's like they're talking
about what it takes it takes two-thirds
of the the Senate to make that decision
and so we're we're talking big numbers
it's it's highly unlikely and so what
then applies what applies are the rules
that Congress decides to apply to
themselves and that is what rules
yeah but congressman I know you didn't
write the rules Grassley did back in 95
and I like Senator Grassley I think he's
not a phenomenal job on most issues but
are you gonna say tonight that you will
fight for removal of mandatory
counseling and a confidentiality
provision and any future legislation
because I see their different versions
of this floating around Capitol Hill the
the the legislation that I have
would remove the the mandatory
counseling it would also make a member
of Congress personally liable if they
engaged in this type of behavior it
would also provide what about the names
you guys get to keep secret or we are no
no no we do the names the name the name
of the member of Congress or if it was
someone on their staff would be included
that would have to be reported within
sixty days at the end of the year there
would also be a survey done every year
so that you have staff conveying what
they feel the culture is on Capitol Hill
so there's a lot there's a lot to this
bill I totally agree with what the
professor says things need to change the
bills and I'm a part of would do that in
custody and Congressman Costello is part
of the he's a change agent in that so I
don't mean to come down I new on this
but I still can't believe this ever
existed on Capitol it is preposterous on
both sides men can be victims women can
be victims men can be victims of false
accusations and we must say that there
are false accusations and women can be
victims men can be victims both can be
but there I'm glad this is going to
change professor thank you
happy Thanksgiving to both of you